خروج لزيلاسكي خارج العاصمة فهل
تقترب الحرب من النهاية ان حققت
اقتربت روسيا من احد اهدافها
الرئيسية في اوكرانيا مع اول
لاحياء احتلال اسرائيل لمدينة
القدس خلال حرب عام سبعة وستين
الشرطة الاسرائيلية في محيط
وداخل البلدة القديمة في القدس.
الفلسطينيون خرجوا لمواجهة مسيرة
الاعلام التي نظمها مستوطنون
الفلسطينيين بالرصاص المطاطي
وغاز الفلفل خلال مواجهات مع
وقال المتحدث باسم وزارة
الخارجية الامريكية ستواصل
لتحقيق المزيد من والازدهار
للجميع. قال رئيس الوزراء
الصنع من صواريخ هيلفاير
الامريكية. جدد الرئيس التركي
انزعاجها من تجريم البرلمان
العراقي للتطبيع مع اسرائيل.
الولايات المتحدة دورها كشريك
قوي وثابت في دعم اسرائيل بما في
جديدة ضد التنظيم الارهابي داخل
سوريا. الخارجية الامريكية تبدي
طائرات من طراز ابابيل خمسة التي
قالت انها مزودة بنسخة ايرانية
مسيرة في قاعدة عسكرية تحت الارض
في قلب جبال زاجروس بما في ذلك
متطرفون ومسيرة الاعلام هي عبارة
عن موكب ينظمه المستوطنون سنويا
ورد الفلسطينيون بمظاهرة حاشدة
رافعين الاعلام الفلسطيني.
ويرسلونهم سيدفعون الثمن
بالكامل. عشرات الاصابات في صفوف
الاذاعة والتليفزيون الايراني ان
لدى الجيش الايراني مائة طائرة
بوتين الى اجراء مفاوضات مباشرة
وجدية مع الرئيس الاوكراني والى
طراز سو خمسة وعشرين. الدفاع
الاوكرانية تعلن تدمير خمس
ومفاقمة الازمة الانسانية. ودعا
الزعيمان شولز وماكرون الرئيس
كوناشينكو ان قوات الدفاع الجوي
اسقطت طائرة حربية اوكرانية من
الاسرائيلي نفتالي بينيت كما
قلنا من قبل انتهى عصر حصانة
رجب طيب اردوغان تأكيده على
مواصلة الاستعدادات لاطلاق عملية
ذلك من خلال دعمها لتوسيع
العلاقات مع جيرانها في السعي
فوتشيتس انه اتفق مع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على عقد
ستساعدنا في الدفاع عن اوديسا.
اعلن الرئيس الصربي الكسندر
مدته ثلاث سنوات لتوريد الغاز
روسي الى صربيا. ذكرت هيئة
في اغراق اوكرانيا باسلحة غربية
محذرا من مخاطر زعزعة الوضع اكثر
بتصريحات غير معدة مسبقا. فهل
ستتوقف يا بايدن? الاحداث
موسكو وباريس وبرلين بان الرئيس
الروسي شدد على خطورة الاستمرار
العديد من الدول للعقوبات
المفروضة على روسيا معتبرا ان
الامريكان سيكون من الامن للجميع
اذا توقف بايدن عن الادلاء
والتطورات. اعلن الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي انه اقال رئيس
الاجهزة الامنية في لانه لم يعمل
من اجل الدفاع عن المدينة منذ
ترسانة كبيرة للجيش الاوكراني في
مسقط رأس الرئيس الاوكراني. قال
الكرملين في بيان عن المكالمة
الهاتفية الثلاثية بين قادة
كيم جونج ام انه سيجرهم جميعا
الى الحرب. تحذير التنين الصيني.
يعتقد ان احدها هو اكبر صاروخ
باليستي عابر للقارات. وفي وقت
نشطاء عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو للرئيس
يقوض النظام العالمي الحالي وحجر
عثرة يعيق اضفاء الطابع
دول بتعزيز التعاون فيما بينهم
باخلاء شبه الجزيرة الكورية من
الفرقاطات والغواصات وهي من
مجموعة الاسلحة التي وصفها بوتين
المواجهة والانقسام على صعيد
المجتمع الدولي. واتهم وزير
الغربية والاستثنائية وعقلية
الحرب الباردة سيؤدي الى
حذرت الصين من ان ما وصفته بهوس
الولايات المتحدة بالمركزية
بدء الغزو الروسي. قالت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية ان صواريخها دمرت
جديدة لصاروخ كروز فرط صوتي من
طراز في اطار تجارب اسلحة جديدة
الديموقراطي على العلاقات
الدولية فكيف سيكون رد واشنطن
سابق حذرت كوريا الجنوبية جارتها
الشمالية من رد حازم على اي
الاسلحة النووية. واطلق مجنون
كوريا الشمالية ثلاثة صواريخ
دبابات روسية والتصدي للهجمات
الروسية على شرقي صواريخ
النظام الايراني. هؤلاء الذين
يمولون الارهابيين ويسلحونهم
كيلو في الساعة بمدى يزيد على
الف كيلو متر ويتم اطلاقها من
الانواع من الصواريخ قادرة على
التحليق بسرعة تبلغ احد عشر الف
لقد جن جنون الروس حقا هل تريدون
نفط وغاز روسيا بعد ذلك يتساءل
مسؤولون ان القوات الاوكرانية
تصدت لهجوم روسي على افاد
ان لا طاقة ولا وقود ولا
يورانيوم ولا حتى غذاء. يا الهي
طراز الزيركون اطلق من بحر
لمسافة الف كيلو متر. هذه
جماعية في دومباز. قال المتحدث
باسم وزارة الدفاع الروسية ايجور
ايجاد حل دبلوماسي للنزاع. يتهم
القوات الروسية بارتكاب ابادة
ويدعى بالصاروخ الذي لا يقهر بعد
تجربة ناجحة لصاروخ روسيا من
والنفط والغاز. ان يدفعوا
بالروبيل وكل ذلك يزيد من عزيمة
صحيفة تايمز البريطانية تقول ان
روسيا سيطرت على سوق القمح
كوريا الشمالية من الدول الحليفة
التي انضمت للعقوبات. بينما يقول
بعد هذا التهديد من اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. زلة جديدة لبايدن. تداول
الامريكي جو بايدن في حديث عن
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
وزارة التنمية الاقتصادية. صاروخ
موسكو الجديد. اسرع من الصوت.
الرئيسية في منطقة دومباس. وبعد
زيارة زلنسكي قالت مجلة رويترز
نتوقع ان نحقق ما يصل الى اربعة
عشر مليار واربعمائة مليون دولار
ان دوي عدة انفجارات سمع في
مدينة خركيف بعد ساعات فقط من
هذا كله. ليس هذا فحسب. فوزير
المال الروسي انطونسن وانوف يقول
الخارجية الصيني امريكا بان
اصبحت في الواقع مصدر اضطراب
الطاقة والغذاء وارون قوتكم
عندها. المجنون يستمر باطلاق
على العراقيين للتراجع عن قرارهم
بتجريم التطبيع وفلسطين ترد على
توجه الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي للمرة
الاولى منذ بدء الغزو الروسي الى
موسكو ويرفع من اقتصادها.
والعقوبات فرضها الغرب لكنها
سكوته الدائم. ايران تستعرض
طائراتها المسيرة وامريكا تضغط
استفزازات بالقرب من خط الحدود
الشمالية فهل يستطيع هؤلاء ايقاف
روسية. المجنون لا يتوقف. امريكا
واليابان وكوريا يدينون بشدة
اطلاق كوريا الشمالية صواريخ
باليستية. مؤكدين التزام الثلاث
بشكل عشوائي. مهلا لم ننتهي بعد.
فهناك ما هو اسرع من الصوت.
تحذر امريكا من مواجهة وشيكة
معها. صربيا حليف جديد لبوتين
ايضا? روسيا تحذر الغرب بشدة اما
ان تنفذ مطالبنا او سنقطع عنكم
بذلك? لا ليس بعد. فالروس
يسيطرون القمح العالمي وماذا
صواريخه وكأنه يقول هيا لنشعل
الحرب. لقد تأخر الوقت والصين
بانها لا مثيل لها واعلن الجيش
الروسي انه نفذ بنجاح تجربة
العالمي. وهنا يؤكد الروس للغرب
وامريكا وجميع الدول غير الصديقة
خرج زلينسكي من عاصمته ليطارده
القصف الروسي وتم قصف المدينة
تقترب من هدفها الاول بالسيطرة
على دومبس. فهل يكتفي الروس
زيركون الذي يدعى بالصاروخ الذي
لا يقهر. ليس ذلك فقط. موسكو
من عائدات النفط والغاز الاضافية
وفق التوقعات التي وضعناها مع
عادت عليهم بطريقة عكسية. يتساءل
الغرب ما الذي علينا فعله بعد
الكرملين فلاجل القمح على الغرب
رفع العقوبات ولاجل الطاقة
شرق البلاد. فيما تحكم القوات
الروسية قبضتها على المدن
زيارة الرئيس الاوكراني فيا له
من رد سريع وخاطف. رد موسكو
فهل تنجح باخافتها? واردوغان يشن
عملية عسكرية في سوريا. او خروج.
مسيرة الاعلام بمظاهرة اعلام
حاشدة. بينما تهدد اسرائيل ايران
والمانيا وفرنسا الوساطة زلات
بايدن تكثر والامريكيون يقترحون
موسكو هدفها هذا?